simplify 16x plus 14 minus this entire
quantity 3x squared plus x minus 9. so
let me just rewrite it and i'll get rid
of some of the parentheses if we can so
we have the 16x right here
16x
plus 14
plus 14 we don't have to have those
parentheses it doesn't change the order
of operations and then we can subtract
from that well we can just distribute
this negative sign so instead of having
a positive 3x squared if we multiply
times this negative 1 it is minus 3 x
squared that's that term right over
there
and then you have this x over here it's
a positive x but it's being multiplied
by this negative 1 out here so it is
minus x
and then finally you have this negative
9 out here but it's being multiplied by
a negative 1 out from out in front of
the parentheses so a negative times a
negative is a positive so plus 9. and so
now we can just combine terms that have
the same degree of x in them and i'll
start with the highest degree term the
highest degree term right here and the
degree is just means x raised to the
highest exponent the highest degree term
here is negative three x squared it's a
second degree term x is being raised to
the the second power so i'll just write
here negative 3 x squared it's the only
one we have then we have the x terms
we have 16x
minus x if you have 16 of something and
you subtract 1 away from it you're going
to have 15x so plus 15x
and then finally you have your constant
terms 14 and then you have plus 9. so 14
plus 9 is 23
plus 23 and we are all done we've
simplified we've simplified the
polynomial